good evening everyone good evening and
welcome really delighted to have a
complete full house with standing room
only we really thank you for for being
here i'm gerry savoir the president of
the Santa Fe Institute and it's again a
pleasure to welcome you to our will on
lectures they began in 1994 so this is
the 18th annual ullam lecture these
lectures are named in honor of the great
mathematician the late Stanislaw ulam
who was part of the Manhattan Project
and subsequently lived in Santa Fe as
part of his legacy his library now forms
the core of the Santa Fe Institute
library today I also want to take note
of the very sad passing of Francois
sulam who died this past April at the
age of 93 great friend of the Institute
and many here in Santa Fe but I'm really
pleased that the alums daughter Claire
and son-in-law Steve whiner are here
with us tonight and the light of their
there with us as always we gratefully
acknowledge the support at the Los
Alamos National Bank which supports our
entire public lecture series and we have
one mores he noted on the slides coming
up in in October to this year and also
Jerry and Katie Peters and the Peters
family foundation for their generous
support of the 2011 who alarm lectures
it's now my really great pleasure to
introduce Jim rut who is the chair of
the Santa Fe and soot Board of Trustees
who will introduce our 2011 luon lecture
Jim
thanks Jerry it's a real privilege and
an honor actually to introduce David
Krakouer tonight David is one of the one
of the first people I really got to know
at the Institute when I showed up there
in 2002 and we had certain overlapping
interests and as I started talking to
him I realized now this is a mega mind
my little interest were about one-tenth
of his brain and mind and he fully
covered everything I was interested in
which was quite incredible and as I got
to know him better I realized that even
what I saw at first was just a little
piece of this amazing concept of the
world in the context of what he's going
to be talking about here tonight from
the very small to the very large and
having to do with how information is
processed and stored and changed and
used etc one of the some of the things
that have amazed me about David and his
way of thinking is how he is rigorously
consistent in applying the same
methodologies from very small level
things the molecular level up to the
various highest level things and kind of
refresh kind of the breadth of the work
that he's done over the years I went
back and looked at some of his
publications and found you know things
very low level very specific reactions
in the chains of information and within
a cell all the way up to some of his
recent work in a new journal called Cleo
dynamics the mathematical and
theoretical study of history so it
doesn't get much broader than that and
again David is not a dilettante in
anything he does the rigor that he
brings to the to the small is he brings
the same level of intellectual rigor the
same level of intellectual honesty these
very large very innovative questions
which are just now starting to become
tractable but we might call real
scientific methods and so I'm really
looking forward to this frankly and
expect to learn a lot and you see this
megamind cook it all down to three
evenings it's I think should be a real
adventure david started his academic
career at the universe
the London where he got a degree in
biology and mathematics and something I
did not know until yesterday also
computer science and he then went and
got a PhD from Oxford at in evolutionary
theory again an interesting very unusual
specialty and then he was stated Oxford
for a little while and went on got a
position at the Institute for Advanced
Study in Princeton New Jersey and then
he finally came and joined us here at
the Institute and what 2001-2002 david
and has been here since and has been a
true adornment to the Institute and
again I enjoy introducing him and I look
forward to his program tonight David
come take it away
is the first test of the megamind my
past has extremely flattering an
incredibly misleading introduction as
you'll see in hopefully in this lecture
series if you do choose to come back
there aren't any mega minds this is an
illusion I should say right at the start
there are many of you here tonight in
it's extremely flattering and I'm
genuinely appreciative but it's going to
get so much better tomorrow and the
third night especially and so you really
ought to come back every night because
it's just going to get better and better
and okay so let's get started I have
this little convention I'm going to be
using in this lecture series and I'm not
sure you can we read that on the back
but it says where your thinking cap or
your brain is at risk I will let this
drop down whenever there's a possibility
of a more technical section to the talk
and you can either sit up pay attention
or text message according to according
to your disposition I should say and
Jerry already did that I'm immensely
grateful and very flattered to be giving
a lecture series commemorating these two
extraordinary people I picked out these
two quotes this one on the left is a
quote about Stan ghulam by Francois
zulan where she says ghulam is almost
exclusively a talking man a verbal
person we're not thinking what he enjoys
most is to talk to discuss to argue to
converse with friends and colleagues
relying on his phenomenal memory he
carries everything in his head and I'm
very susceptible to personalities who
can't shut their mouths and one myself
and this was in in Francois Hollande's
recent obituary in the local paper she
was a trenchant observer of human events
from the mundane to the historic an
individualistic charm and warm wisdom
will be missed greatly by friends and
family I didn't know either of them but
it's certainly an honor to be talking
about intelligence named after two such
extraordinary intelligent people so what
is
what is intelligence I am a little of
verse two definitions I've said this a
few times recently because definitions
often give you a false sense of
comprehension imagine how is giving a
lecture series three nights on the topic
of love and you started off by saying
yes but tell us what it is first there's
something incredibly simple minded about
that you'd asked me to give you examples
introduce you to concepts that in
aggregate give you a sense of what that
concept implies and I'll do the same
with intelligence nevertheless many
people have tried and failed the history
is daunting because intelligence is and
presumably that's why there are so many
of you here tonight the central
organizing concept for our species if
you were to say what is it that makes
humans humans well it's something like
intelligence and that distinguishes us
from the rest of animal nature and for
some people like this chap out takes us
closer to God now this is thomas aquinas
this is a quote from the thumber Summa
Theologica I've written in the 14th
century and for him building on
Aristotle who claimed that thought was
something like light noncorporeal
non-material it was the thing that
demonstrated our unique status in
relation to the divine I'm a little bit
more susceptible to the more ironical
frame of mind like Henry Lewis and I'll
let you read that for yourselves who
didn't have it's interesting you'll have
more or less exactly the same reading
latencies and so he was not as fond as
humans as perhaps Thomas Aquinas and
others might have been at least on paper
so in the 18th century there was an
attempt to measure it and it was truly
ludicrous it was based on what they
thought was the outward expression of
our intelligence in anatomy and so over
here you have a typical picture from a
book on chronometry where you're
measuring the dimensions of the head and
that was supposed to give you an insight
into how smart someone was here's a
phrenology where you can basically
palpitate scalp and by looking at the
distribution of bumps on the head
determine how smart someone was in there
all sorts of extraordinary claim
we're simply by looking at
correspondences an outward visit you can
conclude what the character of someone
might be so this man is leonine he has
that ferocious intellect because he
looks so much like a lion so most of you
will be familiar with intelligence from
intelligence tests so this is an attempt
to reduce all of the complexity of your
thought to one number and so I don't
really have to say much more than that
for you to realize how ludicrous that is
the history though is interesting this
is this is been a alfred Binet and he
was a French psychologist and he was
interested in pedagogy and how we could
improve the education of children who
were challenged in one way or another so
his motivation for working on IQ tests
was actually I think quite honorable
because he wanted to identify potential
weaknesses and improve them and the
kinds of tests that we associate with
Binet these kinds of geometric
associative chess and don't worry about
trying to answer it there's no chess
this evening and here he is a
characteristic scoresheet unfortunately
benet's ideas were somewhat abused by an
American actually he's over here this is
henri gouraud he was a eugenicist that
means he believed in breeding humans and
he wants you to use the IQ test to
improve the average intelligence of the
American people and he would do that by
testing people and sterilizing people
who didn't reach the threshold school
and so it's interesting the intelligence
from Aquinas to Goddard was always in
some sense contaminated with ideological
goals wasn't necessarily a very
scientific pursuit more or less
coincident with the work of B'nai is
this guy wolfgang köhler and Koehler was
a Darwinian and he was interested in the
idea that perhaps some of the precursors
to what we consider intelligence in
humans were present in non-human animals
like chimpanzees and he was really a
visionary and he argued very forcefully
and I think quite convincingly
that non-human animals had true insight
not just simple-minded reinforcement
intelligence which we'll get to and this
tradition is continued and I will show
you a short video of a recent study
coming out of Tokyo on intelligence in
chimps that might surprise you there
should be sound here by the way let's go
back yes so the the there is no sound
output on this computer it should be
plugged into the sound
I even rehearsed that earlier on today
so I I was aware of it I was aware of
the possibility so tell me if this works
no
are you going to give me a sign or
do you guys have it up there okay I'm
going to play it again memory bigger
thanks footage from Kyoto University's
primate research institute shows a young
chimpanzee taking a memory test it's not
only is he beating amending the numbers
he's able to remember their exact
positions after seeing them flash on the
screen for less than a second apes
consistently get ten in a row correct
while humans rarely reach six before
failing hey no and I think you should
take this very seriously okay I think
I'm not a people don't realize that
we're not quite as special as we think
and I make that we are not alone I think
a lot of our interest in intelligence
and trying to find it elsewhere whether
it's in God or some other metaphysical
conceit for me is is lonely this
existential loneliness we want something
else to talk to but we're not alone so
here are some examples of definitions
these are some of the most sensible
definitions the ones that I don't like
of the circular ones where they say
intelligence is that which is measured
in an intelligence test which is okay
and that's what the people in Mensa like
so much because that's all they can do
are there and so you'd ask them have you
used your intelligence in an interesting
way and you well I have a high IQ now if
you look at these definitions of
intelligence some of you will be
thinking that sounds awfully familiar
the Faculty of adapting to circumstances
to deal effectively with the environment
if i were to mention those sentences and
think and ask you free associate a
theory what would the theory be
evolution it sounds an awful lot like
evolution and i'm going to show you that
it is an awful lot like evolution but by
those definitions you will note that the
smartest organism on the planet is e
coli a gut bacterium okay so um so I'm
going to try and give you my insight I
know it gets data it just gets better
i'm going to give you my insight into
intelligence and and you'll see there
are some rubik's cubes on the stage and
i just want you to think about something
and this prop i'm now going to make use
of the probably not going to solve it
but i'll show you something notice the
following
notice how hard it is for me to go from
this configuration where the faces are
in some sense randomized and I not quite
sure how to do it but I'm sure some of
New Orleans can do it in six seconds
which is the record but how easy it is
me because in this blue beautiful
pristine Cuban totally mess it up why is
it easy right easy to do that but very
hard to the opposite what's going on and
that in that distinction lies the
essence of difficulty in the essence of
intelligence so here's a guy trick from
26 years this is wonderful quote here it
says his wife Jeanne 47 I don't know
they write that in American newspapers
but they always have to give the age in
English said it felt like there had been
three people in their marriage two
people and a cube and it's up for you to
decide which with the cube what I'm
going to show you now what I'm going to
show you now is a competition where a
young kid he's presented with a Rubik's
Cube like this he gets to look at it to
remember where the colors are he can't
manipulate it and then he's gonna put a
blindfold on and he's gonna solve it
blindfolded that's what you're going to
see so here he is being shown the
randomized cube and he's inspecting you
notice he's not manipulating
no he's not otherwise compromised this
kid is really smart
okay almost there last look on it goes
oh okay okay yes sir remark okay so we
have here haha I would do the same 26
years 45 seconds blindfolded now most of
you would say wait III so who's smarter
well I am that's a hard one the record
for solving the rubik's cube without a
blindfold is five seconds from a random
initial configuration how does he do it
what's going on here okay so I alluded
to this sort of idea when I was telling
you what was more demonstrating which
was more difficult in some sense this
has to do with probabilities with odds
the easy thing to do is to get the
Rubik's Cube wrong right because there
are many many many ways to do it wrong
there's one way to get it right it turns
out in fact that there's a 1 in 43
quintillion probability of getting it
right so you're never going to do it by
chance alone okay so somehow what we
mean by intelligence right is moving
from a very probable configuration easy
to a very difficult one improbable in
fact intelligence is fundamentally about
searching for answers in what we would
call scientifically a very high
dimensional space now you might say wait
a minute there are other things that are
hard in that way like athletic prowess
so for example getting a basket ball
into a basket well that's improbable too
because there are so many ways of
throwing at the wrong direction getting
it there that right trajectory but we
don't think that's intelligence after
all that's our intelligence that that's
Talent well I'm here to tell you that
that distinction is totally bogus from
the point of view of your brain you care
about that distinction culture cares
about the distinction your brain doesn't
and as a matter of fact in terms of the
number of calculations required for your
brain to solve a rubiks
q as opposed to getting a basket a ball
into a basket in a parabolic trajectory
while in motion is far more complicated
we can build computers that solve a
Rubik's Cube effortlessly there is no
such computer or robot that can play
basketball it's a harder computational
problem so okay are saying wait a minute
maybe this is an abuse of the concept of
intelligence because I granted
computationally athleticism is perhaps
more difficult but we have something
else in mind what we have in mind is
deduction what we think intelligence
really is is not being good at tennis
after all good you know damn it that
guy's better than me and starting not
smarter than I am and it's sort of
solving problems deductively and we'll
get into what these things mean in a
minute somehow what mathematicians do
that's smart but not sport I'm going to
be arguing over the course of these
lectures of that prejudice that can see
that unscientific assumption has led to
us not really comprehending what
intelligence is and that it really
refers to a much more general set of
mechanisms which include deduction but
also include motor induction athletic
ability and the key to understanding it
will be to break it down into four
constituents one I call representation
or encoding inference and strategy so
just to make that a little bit more
obvious if you see an apple at the other
side of the room and you want to eat it
first of all you have a strategy says I
want the Apple you have a goal okay then
you have to represent in your mind's eye
moving towards the Apple and eating it
right so that's a representation and
then you have to do a computation which
tells your legs how to move to reach
your target so any active intelligence
always has at least these three
ingredients right the goal a
representation and a computational
active inference and we'll get into
these in some detail because tonight I
want to lay the ground plan for what's
about to come how the machines do this
do they do this
and so competition is the fourth because
competition is the thing that I'll be
telling you that generates
representations allows you to do
inference and so forth so here's a
simple example of the Rubik's Cube but
it only it's like a coin for a Rubik's
Cube and I'm going to say to you
manipulate the coin such that from an
arbitrary starting configuration heads
is up I can click what I can do hatch
right it's not a hard search problem
right it's not fundamentally different
from the Rubik's Cube right and you
would you say good got it heads up x-pro
ability 14 X heads now this way of
thinking about intelligence has its
roots in some very interesting theories
in physics and this will be a little bit
of an introduction to some ideas that
you might not be familiar with and so
here we have on earth or
it's not difficult it really isn't it
just might seem a little bit abstract in
the 19th century there was a great
interest in what a law of physics was so
we had sort of it no Lord theory of
gravity to the law electromagnetism
which is aboard and these were a
slightly different kind of law these
were laws in thermodynamics and these
what are called statistical laws the
theory of heat and temperature and
pressure in the concept that i'll be
using entropy so entropy basically means
for our purposes randomness so when you
take a Rubik's Cube and you shuffle it
you're increasing the entropy making it
more random but when you solve it you're
reducing the entropy making it more
ordered so entropy in some sense
captures what we mean by being
intelligent because it's by reducing it
you're solving a search problem and this
was a big problem for the universe
because why if entropy always increases
which by the way is the law the second
law of thermodynamics entropy always
increases why is the universe ordered
right why why is the earth here why did
the earth accrete why are we here why
doesn't everything just randomize and
the argument typically is that the the
universe is like a Rubik's Cube that at
the very beginning was started in the
ordered state and in time it's being
shuffled but sometimes there can be
minor deviations from that second law
which lead to ordered states like our
solar system and Maxwell thought about
it in the following way imagine that you
have a box like this and that box has a
wall in the middle and there are
particles that move fast and there are
particles that move slowly and if you
take the average of things moving fast
we call that hot and you take the
average of things moving slowly that's
called cold that's what hot and cold are
and he imagined a little demon and the
demon would have a little lever and
whenever a hot particle move from your
right to left you would let it through
right a cold from left to right you'd
let it through but not anything else and
in time you'd move from a situation
where hot and cold particles fast and
slow are randomly distributed
to one where you have all heart in one
chamber and all cold in the other set
the rubik's cube road Maxwell's demon
was me or that smart kid solving the
Rubik's Cube moving to a configuration
of low of low entropy picking up randoms
and a very famous another physicist
William Thompson who you might know his
Lord Kelvin said for that to be possible
for a system to move out of it
equilibrium you need an intelligent
demon because the demon has to see the
individual particles right and he has to
decide based on judging their velocity
whether they should go left or right
okay so the only way you could move
violate the second law of thermodynamics
with through an intelligent agent as
I'll show you in the third lecture
intelligence doesn't mean divine or us
it could be a robot or simple mechanism
but nevertheless it has to have
representation in prints and strategy
now something interesting happened in
the 19th century in parallel so this was
about how the universe gets ordered
there was another theory we call it
Darwin's theory of natural selection and
Darwin independently discovered the
Maxwell's demon didn't realize it and he
discovered it first but you turned the
Box on its head instead of having left
and right you have time instead of space
so you have generation one and
generation 2 and organisms that are well
adapted to the environment get to pass
through this filter like the particle
did and the ones that don't stay behind
and this demon instead of looking at
particle velocities looks at how well
adapted they are to the environment it's
exactly the same thought experiment
turns out you can write them down the
same way mathematically but the Darwins
demon is much more complicated because
just not such as fast and slow its
structure right whether they've got legs
or arms or wings or leaves and so forth
there's another characteristic of the
Darwins demon which is very interesting
and that is in time the particles yes
that's unfortunately that some
Archbishop Wilberforce who
who doesn't make it through except in
the annals of sort of embarrassing
history and what happens to the
particles is they come to represent the
selection pressure itself so what we are
as organisms as we evolve are
reflections of the selection pressure
and think about it to survive you have
to predict the world in which you live
and to predict it you need to model it
okay so a big difference between living
systems and non living systems right is
even though there might be some proshow
intelligence in the physical one the
physically biological one does this
representational trick the kind of hard
thing to get your head around but it's
critical and so hence the title where's
this adversarial called chair for the
last ten years I've been sort of
worrying about well does thermodynamics
have anything to do with evolution what
does this have to do with cognition it
felt to me almost at some level they
were all related and recently I feel
have made a little bit of progress and
and there are a set of theories it all
look unbelievably similar so here's the
Maxwell theory and that's about the
selection of improbable states like the
cube right Darwin's theory the selection
of organisms the theory of learning of
operant conditioning the selection of
behavior if you do something repeatedly
that gets rewarded you'll do it more
often and the theory of games which is
about strategy the selection of strategy
and when you write these down
mathematically they all look the same
and so it looks as if there's a more
general theory which I would call a
general theory of intelligence that
subsumes all of these other theories
okay this one's kind of interesting cuz
as I said it's physical whereas all of
these are living but it will make the
point that I want you to understand that
physical systems do have proto
intelligence simple form of
representation okay so that's the sort
of hard bitch here's an interesting
point I was looking for quote did Darwin
sort of get this at all Doron sort of
seems we've got everything at sound for
you a bit like Aristotle you'll
eventually find something oh no darling
did it and this is a
from a notebook it's called notebook em
he was labeled his notebook m-meant
metaphysics and morals he wrote it when
he was 29 he'd gone back from the Beagle
by then and he raises free will is to
mind what chances to matter through
losing to the possibility that there was
a connection between fundamental
theories of entropy and non living
systems and randomness in living systems
so now I'm going to tell you what these
things mean and it will be fairly
straightforward because I'm going to
build on them as we move along of these
three nights and I mean if you nice
examples that I think will surprise you
about what non-human animals can do
representational II and inferential II
I'll say less about strategy because
everyone I think knows what that means
and in dexter 3 i'll talk about it in
relation to machines that would like to
beat us at various games don't worry
about that it doesn't really matter um
let's go to this
they may do yeah I didn't come to fight
him to my career and leggy go tearin'
sida Tevita he did red bean crop read in
theory
great that you're Greek so say any allah
meri jaan school to spill any fracas at
you later then oh I said to be mourning
Earl Howe TV sir oh yeah inin comments
gosh italy sucks peter you can end Ont
about a shiksa get in your dart Willis
blush Ackman do you mean sup y'all ready
real quality offaly Vaseline yesterday
mood spill I animart sorry um I
you fix fact de paseo best saw in the
sauce
right so Ches Ches rather death is vain
spread it and not very frightening and
if that was death approaching I wouldn't
be too concerned and so you know where
did Bergman get this idea it's quite
interesting the idea came from a mural
in a church in just north of Stockholm
in Sweden painted by Albert respect or
in 1480 and it's in a tradition of
popular visual Bibles it's hard I
couldn't find a source for an earlier
representation of chess where death is
playing a night but the point about
chess is interesting and that is it it's
become somehow the canonical problem for
us to solve if we want to understand
intelligence in extra 3 i'll talk about
this a lot why is it that chess is so
important to us even though it's so
removed from everyday life we all know
that chess players a good nothing but
chess right especially the very good
ones why is it the model of intelligence
is so we live at range and I'm going to
claim that the reason it's the model of
intelligence is because it has all of
the ingredients of the intelligence that
is it has inferential properties
representational properties strategic
properties in highly competitive
properties that culminate in death
because fundamentally that's what the
stakes are in this game intelligence is
about cheating or outwitting death as
the night judge in the Seventh Seal so
here are some quotes just to make my
point this is a sustained ian king of
the seventh century if a ruler does not
understand chess how can he rule over a
kingdom probably very well alright we
know the answer that were nevertheless
it was believed that to train yourself
to be a great warrior you'd be better if
you understood chairs here's another one
with representation this is kind of
beautiful from curler when a chess
player looks at the board he does not
see a static mosaic a still life but a
magnetic field of forces charged with
energy as Faraday so the stresses
surrounding magnets and currents as
curves in space or as van Gogh sore
vortices in the skies of Provence
amazing and here is I Sir Arthur Conan
Doyle of course the writer of that the
show
homes there's not the mystery and ten
murders that there is in one game of
chess okay so that's what's going on
chess is actually challenging us to
think about these three characteristics
very carefully so let me now talk about
representation and flesh out these
concepts and a little bit more depth so
one of the most famous representations
that you're all familiar with in culture
is number systems here is the Babylonian
number system written on a cuneiform
tablet its base 60 right sexagesimal is
a great great word here's my on this is
in honor of Jerry this is base 20 they
also had the 0 and here is the Roman
Decimal System these are ways of
representing numbers in the world
abstractly and they all have the
property right of being Universal in the
sense that they can represent any number
of arbitrary magnitude ok so their
representations a number that are very
powerful but they have two other
characteristics that i want you to
understand which is what a critical to
comprehending representation one of them
is what i call compression of
representation and here's how you think
about it here's the here's a number 1994
and I've written it in Roman in
Babylonian and Mayan and from now on I'm
only going to write things in in in in
Arabic and Roman numerals because it
took me about an hour to understand how
to do that and I wasn't going to do it
for every other number and so here's one
as another number of 2998 and here it is
written in Roman numerals his 7970 six
and you'll notice pattern down here we
have an even more efficient way of
representing of decimal Arabic numbers
here's Roman that does pretty well a
thousand oops 10,000 oops what is it
about our number system well it has this
extraordinary property that you can
write down arbitrarily large numbers in
a very small space this is a critical
concept is ripped in representation and
it's a part of what I'm going to tell
you intelligence
very efficient representation of a
concept okay here's another one i'm
going to call composition of
representations all of you in this room
can effortlessly do this right because
you know you just have to add a zero how
do you know how to do it with Roman
numerals how does that work it doesn't
work you do it by memory okay there
isn't a rule and look down here it gets
worse that that's harder they're
probably very few of you who could do
that in your heads but you could easily
do it on paper that on the other hand
would take your gaze on paper right
unless first you turned it into that and
then you turn it back into that which is
cheating here's another one this is very
interesting that is no harder than that
right a million platter million two
million one plus one is two that's kind
of extraordinary that the difficulty of
solving an arithmetic operation is
independent of magnitude and that's all
a property of the representation that's
not true with many of the other number
systems that I showed you so now I'm
going to go from cultural concepts of
representation just because I thought
you would be familiar with them to brain
concepts of representation so this is a
famous Canadian neuro scientist
neurologist while depend and he mapped
the brain literally he was interested in
performing operations on epileptic
patients to remove the damaged tissue so
that the electrical activity would no
longer propagate to encompass the entire
brain which happens during a grand mal
epileptic seizure and to do that he had
to induce artificially a seizure so he
plays an electrode on an exposed brain
tissue move it around until he hit the
point which was the locus of damage and
he would realize that's the thing I
should remove his or barbaric but that
bit the procedure worked fairly well in
the process he realized that by moving
this pin over the brain they were
feeling sensation
in their body like pin here would make
your toe tingle up in here would make
your finger he realized that you could
map to the surface of the brain the
surface of the body because you knew
what the corresponding points were so
this was your finger well that was your
palm and so forth and that's what these
maps are so this is cerebral cartography
and that's what your body looks like
represented on your hemispheres okay so
you'll see some interesting patterns
you'll see that your hand takes up a lot
of brain tissue right whereas your
forehead or your back doesn't right and
this is this notion of the efficiency of
representation because the more
sensitive the area the more brain tissue
it requires okay so that's what i mean
by efficiency here and here you can see
the tongue it's kind of ugly it takes up
a huge amount of space so this is kind
of funny so if you look at how at least
the Western male with one possible
modification would like two of you
himself at under ideal circumstances
that's how we might like to think of
ourselves this is how our brain in fact
sees us males now we've corrected the
one possible problem but we've
unfortunately introduced a whole number
of others that seem insurmountable but
the point you'll see that's vile
intriguing is at the brain as i said
before apportions more neural real
estate to areas where you require
greater dexterity or sensitivity and
here are some maps of animals which are
quite intriguing here's a raccoon on a
raccoon it it puts a ton of brain tissue
on to its pads okay here's a catch and a
rat and they have a lot of
representation on the face in the
whiskers the risk is incredibly
sensitive and this is kind of
interesting this squirrel it's all lip I
have no idea why squirrels need very
sensitive lips but that's what they are
now I mentioned to that's efficiency
range now let's talk about composition
and this will surprise you you're all
familiar with the idea of a brain scan
and that's what these things are and
what you see over here is if you would
just stick a big
sensor of your head and you moved your
foot or your arm different parts of your
brain would light up right and so here
look look at this one blue foot
movements when you move your foot red
finger movements right and it's nicely
symmetric but what's very surprising is
if I say the word shin or tow it maps to
exactly the same neurons that the motion
maps to that's actually very weird right
so somehow it's not only your sensory
system that has a cerebral map but the
words associated with your limbs they're
composed in the same neural tissue and I
don't have sandy Blake's Lee's here
tonight but sandy who is a local writer
on neuroscience has been very interested
in these kinds of phenomenon so it has
another feature which is this
competitive feature in this you probably
all know by intuition and here's another
brain scan and i'm going to show you the
following you ask two months of people
to memorize words a group of blind
people and a group of sighted people
okay and here the number of words and
this is okay so this is the percentage
of words remembered the first thing to
note is that the sighted people only go
up to about eighty four percent and the
blind group has a much better memory for
words okay but the other interesting
pattern is what you're actually
measuring here is the activity of the
visual cortex not the area that normally
remembers words at all okay what's
happened in these blind people is that
the area of the brain that normally
remembers visual scenes or contributes
to seeing the work has been taken over
by neurons that represent words so brain
tissue has this interesting
characteristic that if it's not being
used it can be requisitioned for another
function competitively alright so
competition among cells sharpens
representations and recruits in your
resources blah blah okay
so that was a little bit on on
representation ok making analogies
between our external representations of
number and efficiency and
compositionality and the brains way of
doing it now this willing I think the
Santa Fe audience will particularly
enjoy because it's about art now many
people say no yeah when it comes to a
movement everything can do that and but
there are things that we can do that no
other species possibly drizzle art
appreciation I mean humans uniquely
appreciate music and fine art so i'm
going to show you that's absolutely
untrue and in fact that pigeons can
outperform our art critics before I do
that I need to introduce you to the
basic concepts of inference so you've
all heard of deduction and induction
maybe you haven't heard of abduction so
what's deduction well that's the sort of
idea you know Socrates is a man all men
are mortal Socrates is mortal that sort
of stuff you have to learn about
deduction induction slightly more
interesting and that's when you go to
the window in the morning and you see
that everything's wet and you say
probably rained last night that doesn't
follow logically right from the axioms
but it follows from experience that's
what's inductions all about abduction is
the hardest one associated with Charles
purse an abduction is the construction
of truly novel ideas not deductively or
necessarily experientially but sort of
out of nowhere and it's the one that I
think science has made almost no
progress on so here's deduction right in
its purest form this is the principia
mathematica p.m. to those who know it
well it was written in the 1910s and
just to show you how hard deduction is
it was written by of course out you know
Whitehead and Russell here's Paige 362
and by page 362 you've worked out that
one plus one equals two
now you last that's very hard to do it
deductively from first principles okay
so here's induction is a weak form of
induction many of you will see two
things in that image you'll see a face
it actually looks rather like the young
Charles Darwin actually prematurely
balding but it it also looks like a lady
wearing a fur coat in a word about to
cross a bridge in some unspecified
middle European capital right that
doesn't follow logically it follows from
your experience of vision seeing scenes
it's a form of visual induction and his
or his a strong form of induction this
is isaac newton Sir Isaac Newton was
told about the orbits of the planets and
he was able to write down his so-called
inverse square law of gravity where he
somehow compressed condensed a lot of
observation to that little formula which
says that the strength of gravity is
proportional to the product of the
masses divided by the distance squared
times of constant that's induction to
let's now get to up that light sort of
weird moving around so ok who painted
that all right yes you see if I put an
equation going ruin sure when it comes
to painting in this community who
painted that Picasso how about that one
morning a to slightly less well known
about that I've got kind of cast a
50-percent brought fifty percent ashley
Picasso but it's reasonable so you know
that requires quite a bit of knowledge
ride you have to into a number of art
galleries and you can impress your
friends by saying you know that's a
lesser-known Brock well here's a pigeon
that's going to do exactly the same
thing so this is some work that came out
of Japan the Japanese seem to be doing
beautiful studies on animal cognition in
95 and what they did is the following
they trained pigeons to be able to
identify paintings by money or Picasso
so what you do is you like us you take
them to an art gallery you showed me
that some money and not quite but you
reward them you take the reward them in
a sort of skinner box they learn that
yes you've got it right you got it right
and you reward them for choosing the
right artist and hear the results a
little bit daunting but they're quite
interesting so here is a pigeon it's
trained on Monet and I'm gonna explain
what this means this means how often
they respond think of it as how often
they get it right and here as a pigeon
trained on Monday and this is what it
does when it sees the money it starts
pecking a lever morning my money okay um
if you give it up a caso doesn't pit
leave it all very rarely so now these
are paintings that they've seen in the
past so this is the chest of memory is
that a money whether it's a Monet no now
look over here these are pigeons trained
on Picasso okay and they do the same
thing in verse right you show them the
Picasso Picasso Picasso give them the
money no I don't know that is ok but now
you see something very intriguing what
this means down here I don't show at the
bath if you can see that that's the
money this is when you take them on it
and you flip it left to right and this
is the money when you turn it upside
down and you can see if you do that with
a Monet to a pigeon who memorizes manas
they do less well right they say yeah I
think it's a money certain on Picasso
button and so that's what's happened
here it's been reversed doesn't do as
well but this is cool but what happens
to the Picasso train pigeons you show
them at the cow so right and then sorry
I know that's too good to skip right um
go back back back yes okay all right
when the Picasso pigeons are trained and
you turn it upside down I can't tell the
difference I suppose wait or reverse it
always the same this PAGASA we are
nothing so not only do pigeons remember
paintings but they're incredibly
reactionary art Rogers right because
right because that's precisely what your
friends who don't like modern art always
say well you could turn upside down
would make any difference
okay now well it isn't that easy right
let me do that again that's not easy now
that's an upside down Picasso in a right
way up the castle groups which is the
right way up now they also do you'd say
well that's just memory now i'm going to
show you i'm going to shoot inference
i'm gonna show you induction so this is
absolutely as before but instead of
showing the my money that they've never
that they've seen before you show them
that they haven't seen before so this is
what we be cool out-of-sample right so
this is testing them out of sample and
they do almost as well as the one thing
i can memorize so you've never seen that
painting by money before ceremony
pigeons can do it but what's even more
remarkable is you show them a suzanne or
a Renoir and they'll say you know that's
rather light Monet okay but when you
show them a Picasso they'll say no idea
but you do the same thing in reverse you
train them on Picasso and again you
shouldn't the new Picasso they've never
seen anything that's a big handsome but
then what you do is you show them the
Brock or a Matisse and they say hmm
that's rather like Picasso so not only
can they identify artists paintings that
they've never seen before but they can
identify styles of arch okay which is I
think much more than many of my friends
ready so I think this is truly
remarkable and it's worth knowing so
they can do induction at a very high
level as a pigeon a bird brain one of
these are the Picasso one of these is
abroad any ideas look how similarly
color palette typography that's the
answer the care for but I mean I don't
know now strategy is the third if you
like and I'm going to leave this to
lecture 3 so the all come back it's lots
of fun and but I I didn't want to spend
too much time on it because I think you
all know what that is it's about gold
but it's subtle and we'll talk about it
in terms of machine intelligence later
so this is sort of a schematic of what
I've been telling you there is some
feature in the environment
can Apple as I said before and you
represent it and then you do inference
on it calculation in order to achieve an
output this is the sort of universal
structure of all intelligent systems my
colleagues would be saying to me but
there isn't that just an adaptive system
and I'd say yes and we'll get to how
they differ maybe tomorrow now most
cognitive scientists really are only
interested in the things that interested
in representation in your brain an
inference that you make and the output
and they make an interesting assumption
which I'm going to challenge and that is
that representations are achieved by
putting lots of stupid cells together
down themselves nerve cells and
inference computation on those
represented also done by Dan cells right
but somehow that all that dumbness it
asking for hurt it's almost as good as
you Bing woody or whatever he had on the
sure what that was but it's kind of
intriguing leads to magical Mozart so
extraordinary intelligence in this case
musical intelligence comes out of
extraordinary stupidity of cells
aggregated now this is a quote from a
bit knows it the labor of it nosing a
great philosopher at Harvard and this is
what he said if there is to be an
explanation of how our intelligence
functions it will have to be in terms of
fact as that taken individually
themselves are done for example in terms
of concatenation of simple operations
performed by a machine a psychological
explanation explanation of creativity
will be in terms of parts or processes
that are themselves are not themselves
creative so that's what I showed you
before this is the idea that have enough
stupid self together you can create a
Reese my brain I call that the strong
emergence hypothesis that is that
somehow intelligence emerges out of
scaling lots of stupid bits how a
computer works tons of integrated
circuits have enough of them and you can
play you know an incredibly intelligent
game like war
of warcraft would doom okay and that
idea comes from physics that it's
basically hidden concert borrow from
physics bird from the idea of a phase
transition so at a given pressure and
temperature you all know this from the
kitchen as you increase the temperature
you go from a solid to a gas to a liquid
somehow just changing one thing is
enough to lead to a qualitative change
in the object and that concept of the
phase transition has been incredibly
pernicious a concept in the study of
brain many of my columns like wait it's
the Jesus concept in the study of brain
anomaly I think that's wrong okay I have
an alternative which I call the week
emergents hypothesis and it goes a bit
like this it says if there is to be an
explanation of how our intelligence
functions it will have to be in terms of
factor that taken individually then
cells are lower intelligence for example
in terms of concatenation of simple
average a psychological explanation of
creativity will be in terms of parts or
processes that are in cells less
creative or in the limit in the limit
not themselves creative i'm going to
show you an extra three that's why or i
claim that's why we fail to make
intelligent machines because engineering
is about putting together stupid
components to make smart objects
evolution is about putting together
smart components into intelligent
aggregates your brain is like an
ecosystem of organisms it is not like a
circuit of gates and I'm going to now
show you some evidence indirect evidence
of the hypothesis there I mentioned
epilepsy this is now the end so we're at
the very end our and procedures for
excising brain regions to prevent
epilepsy from propagating the most
extreme procedure you could perform
would be to sever the connections
between the two hemispheres entirely
resulting in really a single cranium
with two brains not connected now under
the strong emergence hypothesis for
intelligence what would happen if you
were to cut your CPU in your computer
half well it would go away wouldn't work
or maybe it will be half as powerful
okay under the week emergence hypothesis
you'd have to intelligences because you
can buy separate as often as you like
and they'll always be something there
that's truly intelligent now these
procedures were in fat conducted and
they were conducted by a collaborator of
ours could make Gazzaniga he started off
doing these experiments at Caltech with
a colleague of Murray's called Sperry
and I'm now going to show you a video
and he'll explain to you what's going on
which I think will surprise you and if I
might explain it again afterwards i'm
going to show you something so just as a
quick remark you're going to see you're
going to see an interview with a patient
who has had the two hemispheres severed
okay i'm going to show you some things I
just want you to tell me what you see
and here we go ready look right it done
okay right okay you ready Brad's dock
creeks yeah when Jill focuses on a point
right but I everything to the right of
the point goes to his left brain the
dominant hemisphere for language speech
right so we can see here that when they
flash a word or a picture the Joe is
easily able to name it see it close your
eyes and your left hand do a little work
so that winch was right hemisphere it
doesn't do speech but he cans or if it
was nest okay well you got their hand
and very good now when a word or a
picture falls to the left of a fixation
point that information goes to his
disconnected right half brain and as we
can see here Joe is unable to name it
Joe is able to draw the picture with his
left hand the left hand getting its
major control from the right half brain
where you go okay what you see wheel one
side in Illinois so even though he can't
name it his left hand is able to draw
out the picture of the stimulus of the
picture word to be presented to his
right half brain what did you see
so just close your eyes and draw with
your left hand just let it go
nice what's that so what you see hammer
would you draw that for it no
what Joe and patients like a manner many
of them teaches us is that the mind is
made up a constellation of independent
semi independent agents and that these
agents these processes can carry on a
vast number of activities outside of our
conscious awareness even though that
goes on there's some final stage or some
final system which I happen to think is
in the left hemisphere that pulls this
all of this information together into a
theory it has to generate a theory to
explain all of this all of these
independent elements and so and that
theory becomes our particular theory of
ourselves and of the world so this is a
remarkable experiment you think about it
it's saying that within your own head
you hold to completely diametrically
opposing views simultaneously and if I
ask you to articulate your position
you'll say one thing but I ask you to
draw it or say something totally
different right and these experiments
have been continued so you can ask one
hemisphere you know would you rather
what would you like to be it might say
fireman and the other hemisphere I want
to be a doctor okay so you are not one
person right your multiple people you
know this already because you're saying
I'm not sure I want to do it would mean
you're not sure who's not sure okay and
so what's happening here is that you
have in fact as i'll show you tomorrow
it goes much much further than just two
hemispheres it goes all the way down to
the cells what you really have is you
have cells and collections of cells
voting to be heard okay and they vote
and unfortunately they're not all equal
in the eyes of the world the left
hemisphere gets to cast the final vote
okay and articulate what you think but
what you really think isn't one thing
consciousness and intelligence is not
unitary okay it's the outcome of a
competition among representations at
multiple levels and so this is what's
going on if you remember that picture
what you really have is multiple
hypotheses they're all competing right
and somehow through some process of
election one of those hypotheses wins
through and it's the one that you think
you always meant so here's the summary
for those of you are falling asleep I'm
sorry intelligence describes at least
three capabilities representation
strategy and inference and they're
solving hard problems in the sense of
the Rubik's Cube search problems all
species possess this I think by now you
should understand that and i'll show you
tomorrow even more remarkable
accomplishments there are multiple
levels within you that possess that not
just one and that competition among
these characteristics representations
and inferences at one level form the
representations and strategies at
another and the final level being the
one that I might articulate so in
lecture 2 i'm going to take some of
these ideas that you now comprehend
effortlessly and i'm going to tell you
how it evolved what makes us else Marge
how to sort smart cells make super smart
brains and how we as a species might be
different that is what is the true
nature of human intelligence and I'll
tell you right away it's not language ok
that's what everyone will tell you I
think that's bogus now just as a sort of
fun closing video some of you in the
audience might be saying you know oh
he's so steeped in this adversarial
competitive mindset you know the world
isn't like that it's not competitive and
teeth game like chess I mean after all
we play it to amuse each other we play
it because we enjoy it and I don't know
if this doesn't disabuse you of that
idea nothing will it's just after the
talent but the guys reached the top of
the ones who keep at it but have the
character they don't get distracted by
other things in life until they got the
title or whatever they wanted out of
chess you know can you have any other
life and be a great chess player not at
the moment no you know first things
first rank at the title and and what's
the pleasure what's the moment of
pleasure for you is it when you see the
guy in trouble for when was the greatest
pleasure respond to hitting the home run
in baseball ah the greatest pleasure
well when you break his ego
where it's at yeah yeah and when does
that occur when he sees that he's
finished yeah he sees it coming and
breaks all up inside good night thank
you very much
you don't feel obliged to stay as long
as you come back I will take a few
questions if you have any yes right here
in the front yes he wasn't looking at
all so so what was he doing he was
actually using something called Gold's
algorithm he was if you can remember the
configuration of colors on the surface
of a cube there is an algorithm that is
a sequence of rules that's guaranteed to
take you to the right solution and the
oat that's the only way could possibly
do it it's not that he's starting from
scratch each time and mentally
visualizing the configuration of the
cube at each twist as you were pointing
out in fact that that's a key concept
will come back in extra three the way
you solve hard search problems is by
finding rules that you can represent
efficiently and so I think that's what
you were seeing in the video yes let me
go yes please
yeah that's interesting you couldn't do
you you couldn't do that you simply you
could not remember all of the muscle
memories so that to solve that problem
without an algorithm I think you're
right i think he was asking himself okay
i need to get this cube into a
configuration where I know where the
algorithm can be picked up right but he
didn't say okay I know that I'm gonna
have to move it that way first then that
way then that way and that way I
memorized the entire sequence he has an
algorithm that he already knows who
because in some sense the way to think
about it's like this he has to be able
to solve that problem from any arbitrary
initial condition so it's not the
particular muscle motion because that'll
only work for one initial condition but
it's true he did have to memorize the
rules know what we're to our rhythm was
going to kick in to solve the cube
that's right yes please about
consciousness yes do you want to define
phenomenal consciousness yes ah got it
yes yes so this has a very long history
in the study of consciousness everyone
understands that consciousness might be
useful it helps you solve problems but
what people don't understand is why
awareness is necessary right so you go
to the bathroom because that's important
but you don't necessarily have to have
conscious awareness of it right and so
the question is wet wise awareness
useful and I think it's fair to say it's
remained a philosophical problem to this
day as long as if there's a scientific
answer what I think's going on and if
won't satisfy you because it's not an
answer I'm not sure it's even answerable
scientifically in that question is that
the there are multiple competing as I
suggested at the end recommendations and
what consciousness is is an average over
those recommendations so the left
hemisphere the locus that finally
articulates is averaging over all of
these inputs many of which are
incompatible to come up with an average
recommendation and I think you could
test that now why does that have to have
an awareness component I don't know yes
it was new
yes I'll talk a lot about that a lot
about that in relation to machine
intelligence the when we're talking now
about the externalization of the
representation yes let me go over here
Michael yeah well I mean one of the
things that I've always been curious
about is why we're so bad at building
intelligent machines that aren't
basically just an illusion of
intelligence right and it and there's
been a lot of interest in how biology
works neural networks and so forth and I
think a lot of Engineers haven't
understood how biology works because
it's not a neuron is not a gate a neuron
is an organism and so I was simply
alluding to the fact that the way real
intelligent systems works is about
aggregating components that have their
own representational strategic goals but
at a lower level and so I'm not denying
the possibility of discontinuities I'm
just saying the model is wrong one last
one at the back and all that you were
going through you're tired
but that's that's the problem so the
answer to that is there's the
possibility of entropy reducing locally
so on the aggregate if you think of the
whole universe then statistically it has
to be increasing and will increase until
we fall apart but you can have local
violations and so you're right i mean
eventually increased everywhere then
there would be nothing of any interest
in the universe thank you very much for
coming
you